hello and welcome to our webcast MBA
student insights life outside tech at
the GSB my name is Jason Dunford I'm a
first year MBA student here at the GSB
and I'm joined by JB Manu and Jessica
Holton like me they're pursuing career
interests outside the tech sector so
today we'll be talking a little bit
about the student experience here at the
GSB and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we can
so to submit a question to us about what
it's like to be a student
just click the chat button at the top of
your screen enter your question and
click send to all panelists please be
aware that we won't be taking and we
won't be taking questions about the
admission process the application for
financial aid today you can consult the
website or contact the MBA admissions
office for that information all right
let's get started I will begin with
introductions we're web from what we
were each doing before coming to GSB and
what our goals are for after graduation
so I'll go ahead and start again my name
is Jason Dunford I grew up in Kenya came
to the US for college about 10 years ago
I was a international swimmer so swamp
during college and then beyond college
representing Kenya and then after that I
worked a couple of jobs before the GSB
the first one was in electronics
recycling and then after that I moved
into the solar industry and I've become
very passionate about clean energy and
see myself working in that industry
beyond GSB now I'll turn it over to JB
hi I'm JB Mario I grew up in upstate New
York but I most recently I've been
living in Los Angeles prior to the GSB I
worked in the entertainment industry
so I spent four and a half years our
talent agency in concierge and a year
and a half at a TV production company
and I'm looking to get into management
consulting post the GSB thanks JB
Jessica hi everyone I'm Jessica it's
great to be with you here today I grew
up on the east coast primarily New
Jersey and most recently from New York
and prior to the GSB I was in finance I
did two years of Investment Banking and
two years of private equity focusing on
the consumer industry right and
post-graduation
I'd love to start a company in the
skincare industry
great thank you very so let's get
started with some questions submitted by
the audience so the first one did you
come to school planning to work outside
of Tech or did it or did you change your
plans after you arrived maybe do you
want to take one that's done ok yeah I
was pretty I was pretty sick my interest
rate simple because I was very
deliberate and what I wanted to do
working Entertainment for six years I
was ready to see more industries and I
figured the best way to do that was
could go to business school and then
working consulting because they work of
many different industries so I was very
focused into what I want to do point
going into it yeah I was also very
focused on wanting to start a consumer
company what I was really excited about
was just being around the tech industry
and around Silicon Valley and just
understanding that different ways that
people think here on the west coast so
while I was never really interested in
going directly into tech I was
interested in getting the tech kind of
vibe great and for me I'm very
passionate about energy up to you know
working at SunRun solar company and now
exploring ways to go and work in clean
energy back in Kenya where I'm from been
in the u.s. quite a few years now so
when I use the knowledge I gain here the
GSP to go back and do something that
so number two what resources has the GSB
provide you with to explore life outside
of tech Jessica yes yes but in starting
a company Stanford is great at providing
resources that are related to
entrepreneurial pursuits two things that
come to mind are venture studio which is
actually a physical space on campus that
you can work on your company that you're
starting but there's also a huge
community of people who are alumni of
Stanford who were part of interest
studio while they were here and they ask
questions of each other and we kind of
provide resources for each other
in addition classes like startup Garage
offer a hands-on experience and are
really agnostic to what industry you're
wanting to start a company in so they
have a huge focus on providing resources
for entrepreneurial ventures and it
doesn't matter if it's tech or not yeah
so even though I knew I wanted to do
consulting I still went to a number of
the CMC Career Management Center events
and they had a lot of different events
to help me just explore who you are and
explore what you're interested in to
give you ideas of where to get into so I
do not want to do consulting but I said
you know let me try these out they're
actually pretty helpful I said how about
a lot of people they help me even focus
more on consulting so you see mg is a
great resource still and for me they
like Jessica I've had a chance to be
part of the venture studio exploring my
own venture and also taking a couple of
classes what we call across the street
classes in other schools here at
Stanford so I had great opportunity to
take a energy entrepreneurship class
last quarter and really progress the
venture that I'm working on
great when we've on to the next on what
academic extracurricular internship
experiences are helping you explore and
pursue careers outside of attack Debbie
I'll throw that one over to you
ah well having a liberal arts degree and
not knowing business speaketh I'll call
it just going to business school in
general very helpful just a basic the
introductory strategy class and learning
how people in the traditional business
world speak that that alone is been very
helpful and then the different clubs and
stuff as well hope they do okay
yeah I mean for me I'm kind of similar
had a human biology degree so simply
really getting the hard core business
skills has been incredibly helpful as I
think about what I'm going to do next
and then extracurricular Li I'm getting
a chance to head up and just the energy
club which I think will be a great
leadership experience and help me plug
into an MC community Eva diva alright
and that's the next one can you talk
about the social aspects of the
community does it feel like everyone is
only interested in tech Jessica
absolutely not and one of my favorite
things about the GSB is how different we
all are and of course we're extremely
supportive of each other
but seeing where people come from and
where they're going and there's really
no focus I think there's probably slight
focus to wanting to start a company or
be part of an early-stage startup but
for me an industry perspective people
are all over the place and I'm really
excited to see where people go yeah I
would just have a second that even
especially coming from the entertainment
industry which is definitely different I
I know a number of people who have even
come to me actually I'm a VP for the
arts media and entertainment at club and
who want to get to the business and I
know I know first hand of this golden is
to get in there because it's a soul cake
so yeah I was just have a second
everyone is interested so many different
things
I'm sorry Graham so that's probably
helpful people break the tiara okay
great let's see next we have a question
a little bit more about academics and
clubs so how are the industries
incorporated into class discussions what
classes do this really well and do you
have a favorite case so JB
I'm over I think I think many different
classes is very well actually I'm just -
I think we should all answer it on my
favourite case came from our marketing
class it was actually a case on Unilever
in Brazil which is they will create soap
so that you wouldn't think it's very
interesting but it was in the sense that
because they were trying to figure out a
way to break into a certain market and
we were in different groups and you have
to do a roll report and it was just cool
seeing how all the different solutions
each group came up with and then
presented so that was a very fun case
and obviously not tech related at all my
favorite class so far has been formation
of new ventures I don't know if you guys
have taken it but the premise is every
class we have a different case and it's
across all industries Healthcare
financials Tech consumer and we diagnose
what happens in the startup and each
class the founder comes in and talks to
us and provides their remarks throughout
the class as well and so probably my
favorite case for that was a company
called tiny prints which does cards
customized and at the time that was
something that wasn't available to
people and hearing the founders and how
they bootstrapped it and how they built
it from the ground up was really
inspiring for me
Tamia similarly with regards having a
found in the class one that stands out
is my HR class where we did a case on a
company in Kenya called Julie Colima
that did learns to farmers to increase
productivity and the time I came in to
talk to us about issues around it
centralizing you know workers do their
net field stuff to go out there and get
them business and that was fascinating
and for me as someone who comes from
abroad it's it's really cool to see how
they integrate cases from all over the
world into many of these classes
um great let's see you next question how
have you kept yourself from being
pressured into tech with Silicon Valley
so close by definitely there is a pull
where so hey Jessica yeah
Stanford does a great job at two things
many things but two in particular are
reflection and prioritization so in the
very beginning of the year we had a
session about priorities and setting
your priorities and really making sure
that you're focusing on your priorities
rather than being pulled into the
community think and what you think
everyone else is doing so that's
definitely blood through my entire
experience I think also on reflection
making sure that you're in tune with
yourself and what you want to be doing
is something that is known as something
that people do here so I think that that
has really kept me on my track and I
haven't really swayed from it because of
those two activities yeah I completely
agree and one thing I'd also add too is
because Stanford so close to Silicon
Valley and it there's a slight tech
focus you get to see how tech has
entered other industries just because
you're not going to go into the tech
industry doesn't mean technology is not
changing industries so it's actually
very cool to understand that okay I
might not I might not go into tech
itself I might not go look at Google or
Apple but technology is changing many
different like all different industries
good to see that and keep that in the
back of your mind as you look to figure
out what you want to do yeah absolutely
and on that point again that opportunity
to maybe step across to other schools
and legacy as long yeah a lot of
business school students will will do
that so you know get that grounding tech
skills great so what resources are
available to help you pursue a career
shift okay well I can hear you you want
to go that you yeah I think I mean for
me at the CMC incredibly helpful at the
Career Management Center you know you
can go there they have a ton of
resources they're the kind of job kind
of advisors so that that I think it's a
big one JB yeah I was also just going to
add on CMC and the student clubs too I
joined the consulting Club
I remember consulting recruiting as an
undergrad a little bit and thought that
was just too difficult but the
consulting Club and I did so there many
different clubs but they give you the
resources you need it's in the track
you need and then because everyone at
the GSD comes from so many different
backgrounds that your students here are
very helpful as well if you're looking
to change your career just to give you a
picture of that being able to in the
first quarter have 30 minute coffee
chats with people from we have 400
people in our class and I want to learn
about energy or entertainment we have 30
minutes and that really gives almost a
deep dive really quickly and efficiently
right what is the typical day like at
the GSB if there is either typically
Jessica the other day you could talk
about yeah they're very different I say
during the week we're in classes it
depends on the day but probably average
of three classes a day three to four
classes a day and so we spend a lot of
class time and we also kind of
interspersed with that have lunch or
coffee with people who were trying to
get to know or catch up with for dinner
there's often meetings where speakers
come in and you kind of go to that
figure there's dinner provided one of my
favorite things about the GSB is talk
which is tonight every Wednesday night
for us where one student gives a 30
minute kind of talk about his or her
life so that's a good community aspect
I'd say every day has an element of
academic social community and career and
it's really excited know it is the same
and they all go very quickly yeah baby
yeah being I was yeah the only thing I
would say is typical as you know you're
gonna have classes at the same time
Monday 5e or Tuesday Thursday and then
your calendar goes you get invited to
lots of different things and it just
starts to fill up is especially you like
to say yes which you should get to see
lots of experiences so yeah there's
really no typical day yeah I don't know
about you two but I find my calendar
pretty much owns my life yeah and so I'm
better like that well and then we get
weekend to you know we have our social
events and which is a great time to get
the classwork done for the following
week in prep for that okay will you talk
about the global experiences you've had
or plan on pursuing okay
I can I can take that one as a former
athlete I got a chance to travel all
over the world but unfortunately well it
was incredibly fortunate but on those
trips often times it would just be a
pool in the and a hotel so been very
nice for me just having recently gone on
a global experience trip through the GSB
to South Africa with 30 of my classmates
and we really got to explore the country
talk to some incredible leaders down
there so that's been a new travel
experience for me and I'm hoping I can
do a few more of those
during my time yet yes Amelia I went on
a global study trip to Singapore in
Indonesia so you know the service many
trips are 30 students and you're meeting
every day with business leaders and
government leaders it's a really great
way to get to know a country besides the
tourism and so I did that and I'm also
doing a internship in London for four
weeks over the summer which we create
and then looking into planning a global
study trip for next year so the GSB
definitely does a great job at inter
mingling you're kind of global
experiences with your academic pursuits
yeah I mean the global the global
experience is a requirement so you have
to be some global aspect I did a global
study trip to Japan last winter which is
just amazing and applying Sergi mix will
see if I get it so hopefully four weeks
somewhere abroad you want explain a
little bit about what it T mixes alright
so I think you know with you yeah so J
mix is basically from the wedgie it's a
mini we have 14 weeks I think 14 weeks
off for the summer yeah it's a mini
internship so instead about ten we great
weekend trips of it generally around
four weeks can be flexible depending on
the Sun you have where you get like it's
a shy pin to live in a certain country
and work for a company and just really
get to immerse yourself in the
experience it's a great way to have like
a little snapshot into what it would be
like to work abroad or in that
particular industry to it's a good way
to just try it out for four weeks
the next person what exposure do you
have to clean tech renewables energy
efficiency at the GSD I suppose this
one's for me yeah so there are some
clear the classes are focused on team
project development a clean energy
project development and finance and then
of course the engineering department is
it a ton of classes you can take and
design design your
schedule that way and a lot of people
interested in environment can also do a
dual degree it's called a VIP degree and
stay on for an extra quarter and it even
dive deeper and into those subjects
how does social impact in corporate
social responsibility in merging your
GSB experience whether inside or outside
class questions I know like ethics was
one of my favorite classes first quarter
armed and so that that's the class where
you're really dealing with the difficult
questions now the way it's taught the
teacher does not try and make you does
not tell you what's right or wrong you
just have you they talk about business
situations like the LIBOR scandal or the
I forgot what Intel was talking about
getting changing they're changing their
supply chains like make it more like
have safer minerals and they stay so
that God like water minimum and again
like that so that's definitely that's
definitely class that focuses on those
on that has people have those
discussions because I do you think it's
very important and we also have there's
a social innovation Club here and the
energy Club actually we collaborate with
them sometimes and they do a big social
innovation retreats it's certainly that
is a community that you can plug into in
a big way there are also opportunities
to be a part of actual companies who are
doing social good and consulting for
them and it's a pretty time intensive
thing but those people are learning a
lot and the last thing I have is I
haven't quite done it yet but um you can
you can talk to your professors in class
so you can challenge them at some
certain question I'm only bring us up
some listen to an audio book about the
financialization of America and I got
and I'm and it's talking certain things
I'm never learning some things in
finance and I know like in the future I
want to if I hear something it's a
little jarring you can challenge a
professor's like why is this I heard
this I heard that and it can actually
foster a very good discussion actually
right next one how supportive is the
student body do you feel that it is a
competitive environment or supportive
community that's a very strong opinion
is incredibly supportive I have never
been in a community of people that is
it's full of 400 cheerleaders by our
side to help us out um I have never felt
like someone is trying to go ahead and
do something without bringing the whole
class behind them I think some specific
examples are in the first quarter or the
second quarter when some people who had
finance backgrounds or accounting
backgrounds
would just help out and for nothing like
just spends many hours trying to help
their classmates who came from liberal
arts backgrounds and it's really just a
community of help and people are know
that I'm interested in starting a skin
care company and people have reached out
to me to want to share their experiences
and it's really a very very special
community and I don't think there's
anything like it yeah I totally second
that and and yeah if you want if you
want to you know someone to help you out
with a contact you tremendous really
interested in people that are so willing
to do that and I'm just thinking on the
sometimes when you worked on a group
project maybe you don't have a stronger
background it's someone else on your
team I've just found people so willing
to help coach and bring you up to speed
on in those experiences so it's been
pretty amazing and I specifically did
recruiting for consulting which can be
seems like scare some people because
generally like business schools are
theatres into consulting and one is nice
that Stanford is such a diverse
background that it wasn't it wasn't be
again remembering undergraduate 200
people in one room all fighting for ten
jobs Stanford and feel that way at all
because one is like 40 people and then
and then people are just so
collaborative so even in the intense
recruiting of it all Stanford is still
incredibly collaborative and supportive
community and one thing to bring up on
that is that we have a norm of non gray
disclosures so that also helps out
people kind of are on the spectrum of
being super focused on academics and
also prioritizing other things as well
and so not competing for the number one
or number two spot it's not relevant for
us yeah and allowing us to take risks
maybe take a class that if we don't have
a strong background in and we can really
try to push ourselves what networking
opportunities available to non tech
students I can talk about through the
energy club we hosted a careers event in
collaboration with the Stanford and your
club every year we're bringing in
speakers we bring it we have a brown-bag
lunches you know throughout the year so
so we try to do that through the clubs I
don't know yeah I wouldn't go that for
the retail club obviously as you can
tell we have clubs that go kind of by
industry in addition to other activities
and one thing that the clubs do at least
the retail club is at rec so there was a
track to Europe but the one that I went
on was to San Francisco so it was half
an hour away and meeting with various
companies and really getting to know
people within those companies and
networking across retail so Sephora and
Chubby's and other places how invested
is GSB in providing recruiting resources
for students who are interested in
careers outside tanked
but a similar question I think we've
touched on this a little bit the seat
back again the CMC in the club's be just
such an amazing job of giving you the
resources you would need no matter what
like again we talked about the tracks
from some of the CMC and on the
different you can do individual
one-on-one meetings if your CMC adviser
they can help you reach out to alumni
there's plenty of resources that um that
uh that will help you like refine drops
off Isaac yeah
can you speak a bit about any experience
you might have meeting students at GSB
who come from a nonprofit background we
were interested in focus focusing on
nonprofits later in their careers
personally I have a lot of friends who
come from nonprofit brat backgrounds and
the couple they comes to mind are
actually starting a company in this
space and so you know Stanford is
incredibly supportive people who want to
go into nonprofit there's also funding
you can access for your summers to work
with nonprofit companies and that
there's also a fellowship beyond what
once you graduate that you can access if
you're going to be working in a
non-profit career so just be as
incredibly supportive
anything else add from that one is it
common for students post-grad goals to
change over the course of the program
definitely definitely and I think a lot
of people come in not really knowing
what they want to do knowing that they
want to change fields but want to
explore different hypotheses I think
it'll be interesting we're all first
years so it'll be interesting to see
what happens after the summer where a
lot of people have internships and they
test out the hypothesis so do they like
it or do they not or various aspects and
then come back in the fall ready to do
full-time recruiting or go back to the
company that they intern that they'll be
interested to see and it's currently
almost May like we're a week away from a
and I know a number of people who still
don't have internships for the summer
that's because and it's not because they
can't get internships because they're
still just really trying to figure out
what they want to do so even right now
like when people are still trying to
figure out where to explore
we're waiting for the perfect exactly
yeah I have protect me is that someone
can be a big time because it really
helps refine what how your coach is
checking in ready hone in on something
knowing you wanted to enter a non tech
field before entering business school
why did you choose GSB I get identical I
what like GSB it was definitely my top
choice one I lived in Los Angeles so I'm
even though I grew up in the Northeast
it would be I was like it'd be nice to
stand when I'm in the West Coast and I'm
doing the something short term might
want to get that custom media long term
but it's hard to see what I was saying
earlier just how technology is changing
every industry so I wanted to be nearby
detect the tech space because
specifically in media I mean Facebook is
becoming a media company Apple's having
a much bigger space in the media the
media sleaze like your player in the
media space so these tech companies are
me becoming media companies from my
point of view in a sense so I just want
to be around that that sort of like life
I guess
proximity yeah I agree I wanted to be
around big ideas and ideas that are
changing the world and just openness and
new ways of thinking and collaborating
and the GSB was definitely that beyond
that I think the community that we have
all talked about is just unparalleled
and that's really what made GSB my first
choice and then I would also say that if
you want to start a company the parallel
the resources are unparalleled as well I
think it's a fantastic place to start a
company regardless of what industry you
want to start it in yeah I was lucky
enough to do my Under
graduation so is any chance resent a
farmer okay how much does your first and
second year schedules allow you to be
allowed for you to be in
extracurriculars is it recommended to
just one extracurricular like take a new
leadership role would you be able to
participate in a few club so clubs here
are different from at least my undergrad
experience in that they don't really
dominate your social experience if you
don't want them to and so we have
something called and we have the first
five weeks basically we can't be a part
of club and that's in an effort to get
back in the swing of things would be a
student and getting to know your
classmates and so by the time you join
is actually the midway through your
first quarter and I don't know about you
guys but I joined several retail Club
being one of them but also just
activities like the wine circle and the
heat club and so it's throughout your
first year you can definitely be
involved in a bunch of them and then if
you want to take on a leadership
position it's not it's definitely
manageable and I'm doing one it's the
eating close uh but it's definitely
manageable it's kind of like whatever
you want to prioritize is where Asian
spend your time yeah I would agree I
mean in terms of Club leadership I think
it really depends one how much the club
does over the course of the year how big
a role it is how much you want to bring
to the role I do see some people take on
maybe more than one leadership role in a
club but I think typically it's one and
then being a member or something a
supporting role in on the club
but I definitely seems like some second
years they're done now but like who let
a couple clubs one or two clubs they did
Algonquin for like an our vocal fellow
and also signed like quite a gee Miguel
yeah they were very very very busy
because that is a lot but it's doable
non tech buyers how does the GSB prepare
you for starting for-profit businesses
in Africa or low-income countries this
one's for me again and so I mean they've
been quite a few businesses started in
these countries by alums of the GSB so I
have plugged it to the network people
have done that in Kenya specifically you
know that again there's a ton of
resources people who fund in businesses
overseas so you know there's a lot of
potential although innovations have come
out of Stanford for work in low-income
countries one I can think of
specifically came out of the d.school
was a low tech incubator for babies in
low income countries so you know there's
a lot of support here and there's a lot
of precedent to people who have done
that coming out of the GSB and Stanford
more generally action can you talk about
your experiences with faculty
I got very expensive faculty and it's
just funny thinking comparing it to my
undergrad experience where I didn't
really talk to faculty it at all that
often but um I had I've had a couple of
lunches like accounting I was terrified
for accounting because that was just a
class oh this is gonna be the toughest
thing from a non-business background so
I loved the class I had lunch with the
teacher while we were in class together
I've had lunch of the teacher again like
after class so the faculty is just
incredibly approachable we does the way
that the way the schools set up is like
the big dining Arbuckle's like right in
the middle so you see here you see your
teachers yeah even like when you're not
in class with them anymore and like it's
just fun to catch up with them so I just
had amazing experiences of yeah I said
there's people who supportive just like
the community of us is and so I had a
question about a startup and I went in
to talk to Professor for office hours
and she spent way longer than I expected
her to or to have time to because she
really cared about getting to the bottom
of it and problem-solving with me and
it's an ongoing conversation so it's
really actually incredible how much they
want to help us and want to see us
succeed and propel us into the world I
second all of that and I Jade just lost
300 amazing spirit sir
I got invited to go to an ice hockey
game with the patinas they got to spend
time watching the San Jose shot it's
pretty incredible and I actually thrown
one one more take there was one teacher
who they do it down the middle halfway
to the quarter we do our evaluation of
your teachers and one teacher we we
didn't love him we gave him not a very
strong evaluation but the way he
responded to it was incredible to me he
took it and then he like you spend like
one class but we're just talking to us
about like what he can do better how he
can improve experiences from prior years
and the second half of the class went so
much better because that teacher what
really cared about changing the way
you're teaching us
what supporting guidance do alumni
provide I can take that I mean I'm
having just really amazing interactions
with alumni especially ones in who
involved in energy I had a lot of
conversations that way there's actually
a standard professionals in energy group
where they you know they help set us up
with mentors who are working in the
field outside the GSB so incredibly
exploited alumni community I think
that's one of the huge huge pluses of
the gist is that community they get to
plug into that opening which becomes
like a much tighter community that um
you can really connect the omaticaya
number especially during the recruiting
process second something a number of
alumni we're definitely reaching out to
me saying hey you should think about the
sperits why my friend is pretty good and
so and as they had good interactions
been the glow if you've learned credibly
welcome to the emails on the cold emails
if you have a Stanford address and they
are definitely welcome to answering your
questions great so we're almost out of
time today
before we go JB and Jessica any final
words of advice for people thinking
about applying for an MBA I would
probably say look into the community
that you're joining and I think Stanford
is an incredible community but it is one
that is a pretty intense community and
one that really does open up and share
with each other and get to know each
other really well um I don't know if
that's for everyone it's definitely for
me and it works really well for me but
just really understand the community
that you're joining and where you were
playing stuff yeah I now to just be
really thoughtful about what you want to
get out of the experience would then be
also open at the same time because that
you understand like you're going to
change so come in with out with a goal
like the Blues like a loose sort of goal
to see you and leave yourself open to
change I guess my final comment would be
you know if you don't want to you know
you don't want to work in tech there's
plenty of other opportunities that you
can explore the DSP so I don't think
that should be a big concern as you're
thinking about Stanford for an MBA it's
it's an incredible experience for me so
far yeah in a second
right
okay well that's it thank you thank you
two for joining us and everyone in the
audience for participating you can learn
more about the MBA program and the
admission process on the GSB website the
application the application for the next
cycle will be available in June yeah
thanks again and I hope you all have a
great day
you